c'est la mobilisation de la dernière
chance pour les soutiens de julian
assange
à deux jours de la reprise du procès
pour extradition du fondateur de
wikileaks plusieurs dizaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées
aujourd'hui ici la place de l'opéra pour
apporter leur soutien à julian assange
objectif interpeller l'opinion publique
emmanuel macron sur le sort du
journaliste australien d'après c'est un
manifestant la seule et unique solution
pour julian assange est d'obtenir
l'asile politique et a aucune charge
contre lui il est accusé de d'espionnage
aux états unis parce qu'il a froissé
quelques ego en parlant des crimes de
guerre en irak en afghanistan et à
guantanamo et on s'acharne sur lui d'une
manière absolument honteuse et c'est
pour soutenir ce qui le fait qu'il soit
pas extradé aux états unis pour cent
soixante quinze ans de prison que je
suis là il ya cette contestation de de
toutes les oligarchies qui finalement
est en particulier les états unis qui
mènent à qui mène la danse 2 d'essayer
d'éliminer quelqu'un qui fait tout
simplement son boulot de journaliste et
qui est pourtant on lui fait un procès
fallacieux pour parce qu'en fait 1 5
grains de sable dans la machine de big
brother et malheureusement il ya trop
peu de gens qui sentent concernés parce
que sa liberté à l'issue notre liberté à
nous et ça les gens ne comprennent pas
c'est très important
on l'appelle julian assange est
actuellement incarcéré à la prison de
haute sécurité de belmarsh à londres et
en cas d'extradition il encourt une
peine de 100 75 ans aux états unis pour
avoir divulgué des documents classés
secret défense sur les agissements de
l'armée américaine en irak et en
afghanistan
listant notamment la justice britannique
va t'elle oui ou non extradé le
journaliste et lanceurs d'alert
australien c'est tout l'enjeu de ce
procès historique pour la liberté de la
presse et qui s'ouvre ce lundi à londres